now here's what I want to show you just
to make sure that you're doing this
right because it's a bit there's so many
steps right I'll come to your visit
your calculator is even smarter than
what we're just showing right it can
actually go straight to the gradient and
the ways it can do it in one here okay
now the syllabus wants us to be able to
understand how to do it step-by-step
that's one aim in three months and they
gave us a big chunk of space but I still
want you guys to be able to verify for
yourself so come back you store all the
data there in calculator clear it sorry
III one last time shift one to go into
all your options right this is upgraded
in the way to set they're related to
this regression line the line of best
fit so if you go back into fire for
regression you'll see two letters there
at the top a and B a and B just remember
that for a second remember what we went
to mode and I said stat and then I asked
you to choose and there wasn't a label
that said bivariate data and we said oh
it's option 2 and I just don't worry
about it right now then I want you to
pay attention to one said not worried
but just notice do you see what a plus
BX says a plus BX is just another way of
writing the line of best fit the
regression line that a is going to be
the y-intercept could be this is why
it's a bit confusing why I didn't want
you to be distracted by before in this
case they've used beauty in the cake
radio okay
so if I come back out of there I'm going
to go shift 1 5 when I press one I'm
expecting this will give me the y
intercept BAM
in one hit okay so this is a way to
check that you did this right in the
same way you can clear it again your
shapes one five I'm going to get it soon
I'm expecting to get the gradient there
it is it wants you so I would use this
as a check right you can make sure you
go through your steps you've got the
right number
on the the be that over there is the
gradient and the ADA we just found out
we just yet
was the ones that like in the wagon yeah
we just right formula they go okay sir
yeah good question yeah right
so let's come back in I thought okay now
in truth and the reason I didn't show to
you before is because I just then when
you get lost in the in the forest okay
what you actually need to show for your
three marks for your three months is
your use of this formula okay so
therefore let's move this down a little
bit
here's what I'm gonna do to show that
I'd actually used this correctly right
the gradient is actually made of three
things are spending Gatien for why
standard negation maps okay so therefore
I'm going to go to my calculator and my
calculator tells me that R is equal to R
we work this out in part one zero point
nine zero seven at R and I'm going to
multiply that by and I can work out the
standard deviation for y I'm just going
to find it out in in this thirteen point
seven three and I could work out their
deviation X which is nine point zero
five okay so what this slide shows is by
just of the formula and that I
understand how these things fit together
okay in the same way down here through
this other way this other way
the y-intercept is consisting of again
three pieces right there's the mean for
y so I get that from my calculator yet
66 take away what am I going to put next
we're going to find a shape that'll do
okay it's enough to recognize that to
the number in time now by the way I
should point out I should point out I'm
using my calculator to do all this but
do you remember I have it right there
you've got those they've been calculated
for you okay I still suggest that you
use your calculator actually crunch it
out because I was really frustrated this
actually and I had to really really
check this see how here on the question
part one says correct to three decimal
places that is highly accurate have a
look at the data provided here how many
decimal places you see one two zero one
two or zero now if you use these you
actually get if you use these in part
one you actually get the answer wrong
you don't get zero point nine zero seven
which is the L tell you check your
markers you get zero point nine zero six
you're off by the third decimal place
the best kind of a decimal place they're
looking for okay yeah it is a little bit
right so that's why they try to
distinguish for you what saves you from
this is look at the question carefully
part one says verify just let it go are
equals in your calculator don't do any
working for this they're just expecting
you to write the number but there's a
part two they expect you to take all of
the numbers that are there and then go
ahead and put them into a calculator
okay so just coming back
we need to get out a bit happier well
let me show you I'll put them both side
by side so you can see what I'm doing
okay
that's not the window I want there we go
do you recognize do you see where I've
gotten these numbers from is 13.73 in
the nine point zero five see where I've
gotten front okay nice so good you're
right yeah thirteen point seven three
there's 66 and so in here I'm going to
put six point one sorry 69 point four
and when you hit equals you're going to
get this number does that make sense
yeah once you've got those numbers cut
out there is your regression line like